et julien de normandie va donc
s'installer en direct bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin julien de normandie vous êtes
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
mais vous êtes surtout là ce matin en
tant que soutien d' emmanuel macron
puisqu'on en période électorale il ya
des règles électorales évidemment à
respecter vous êtes avec nous pendant un
peu plus de vingt minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
eric richard de la nouvelle république
jean eric bonjour envie d'être avec nous
et manuel maquereau a donc dévoilé son
programme hier plus de quatre heures de
conférence de presse une trentaine de
mesures ont été annoncées trois semaines
avant le premier tour il était temps
quand même mais je crois que hier il ya
eu un vrai débat un vrai débat avec les
journalistes une présentation d'un
programme de manière complète et puis
surtout il y avait une vraie vision que
je caractériserais d'abord par une
ambition et je crois que c'est très
important d'être ambitieux songez que
dans ce projet le candidat emmanuel
macron parle de cet objectif d'atteindre
le plein emploi qui il y a quelques
années aurait envisagé un tel objectif
politique songez que dans ce projet il a
à nouveau l'ambition de réduire les
impôts moins 15 milliards après les
moins 50 milliards de ce premier
quinquennat et donc il ya un projet un
projet ambitieux est également un projet
d'avenir c'est à dire regardez devant
avoir cet optimisme de la volonté comme
disait le candidat hier et je crois que
ce projet d'avenir c'est aussi quelque
chose qui le différencie des autres
candidats on le voit bien dans cette
campagne beaucoup de candidats regarde
derrière regarde dans le rétroviseur et
vous aviez hier un candidat qui regarde
devant coup deux candidats vous pensez à
bien vous avez tout ce qui en fait en
reprenant cette belle formule d'eric
woerth tout ce qui en fait tu regardes
avec nostalgie leur enfance plutôt que
d'essayer de construire la france de
leur enfant et je crois que c'est
essentiel de différencier ceux là ceux
qui reprennent les ficelles des
campagnes dit dix ans ceux qui sont dans
la nostalgie eh bien ils sont
profondément dans une position
différente de cet optimisme de la
volonté réaliste c'est à dire au final
comment on arrive à construire cet
avenir pour le pays tout en ayant la
lucidité de se dire que nous sommes
retournés est retombé dans le tragique
c'est à dire la guerre sur le sol
européen c'est à dire la co vide c'est à
dire le changement climatique et c'est
voilà cette vision est aussi ces mesures
du quotidien qui est le candidat macron
a présenté qu'on va venir évidemment sur
ces mesures est d'abord un mot sur la
méthode ce qu'il en était question au
début du discours d' emmanuel macron oui
de tout à fait donc sur ce
sur la méthode il en propose c'est vrai
une nouvelle y compris bien sûr des
sujets je dirais qu'ils ont qui enquille
ont déjà été portées pour lever des
pleins d des points de blocage il
reconnaît qu'il a été trop solitaire qui
n'a pas assez tenu compte des élus des
français
qu'est-ce qu'il faut déduire qu'est ce
qui va changer vraiment d'abord de dire
et je crois que c'était prévenant hier
lors de cette présentation du projet de
dire que le candidat emmanuel macron
tient compte de tout ce qu'il a pu
apprendre pendant ce premier quinquennat
de toutes les crises qu'il a traversées
que nous avons traversé le pays a tenu
tous ensemble et tenant compte de ce qui
a marché de ce qui a moins bien marché
c'est très important
d'avoir été un président jupiter il ya
un pardon ce raccourci mais c'est ça
alors c'est encore plus précis que ça
prenez par exemple l'hôpital l'hôpital
est un très bon exemple
saleh dans notre pays on sait qu'il nous
faut aller beaucoup plus loin sur
l'accès aux soins sur l'inégalité
sociale liée également à cet accès aux
soins les déserts médicaux vous en
parlait beaucoup ici mais d'autres accès
eux également sur l'hôpital pendant des
années on a dit c'est un problème de
financement pendant des années il
s'avère que à la suite et même avant
l'aco vide la période de la cog vide le
gouvernement s'est engagé à vous mettre
beaucoup d'argent sur l'hôpital le ségur
c'est plus de 19 milliards d'euros est
ce que en dépit de ces investissements
importants tout a été réglé à l'évidence
non et donc ça montre bien que
appréhender un sujet aussi important que
l'accès aux soins mais c'est vrai
également pour l'école ne peut se faire
que par une vision qui serait une vision
réformatrice certes mais fondée sur un
considérant qu'ils seraient par exemple
l'accès au financement et
d'investissement ça doit être construit
et construit avec les parties prenantes
sur l'hôpital pour reprendre cet exemple
c'est de partir du service hospitalier
de l'organisation physique de l'hôpital
de considérer le quotidien de ceux qui
travaillent et considérer également le
service rendu à ce gain les halles que
les erreurs et s'explique par une
méthode pour adultes et 10 avec vous
c'est pas seulement mon slogan de
campagne c'est aussi manuel mais tout
simplement ça veut dire que ça n'a pas
été fait non ça veut dire qu'on a appris
on a appris mais je trouve que c'est
extrêmement simple dans une vie
politique que de dire il ya des choses
que j'ai réussi des choses que j'ai
moins bien réussies ou même où je me
suis trompé et puis il ya cette méthode
cette méthode nouvelle que je veux
incarner avec des chantiers sur la santé
je l'évoqué l'école également les
institutions au son d'un airbus et
surtout que hier et c'est pour moi
extrêmement important parce que c'est la
politique dans laquelle je crois vous
aviez à la fois cette vision est à la
fois ce quotidien on a parlé d'une
france plus résilient plus forte plus
indépendante et des français qui regagne
dans la maîtrise de leur destin
individuel dans cette émancipation
le président de la république a conclu
en réponse à un de vos confrères sur
comment résumer ce qu'il venait de dire
et il s'est exprimé ainsi plus fort plus
heureux tous ensemble et les trois
termes sont essentielles plus
indépendants plus maître de son destin
et on le faisons ensemble parmi les
réformes qu'il a échoué à mener il a dit
elle a reconnu lui-même la réforme des
retraites donc là ils l'ont promis une
nouvelle avec un relèvement progressif
de l'âge de départ à la retraite à 65
ans sur une période de neuf ans qu'est
ce qui garantit que cette fois vous
réussirez cette réforme des retraites
pourquoi cette fois il faut vous croire
alors qu'il ya cinq ans vous l'avait
promise et ne l'avait pas fait alors est
il ya quelques années il ya trois ans
exactement un peu moins même pourquoi la
réforme des retraites avait été arrêté
alors que le processus avait été engagé
parce que nous avons eu la crise
sanitaire c'est à ce moment du début de
la colline que le président emmanuel
macron a dit les conditions ne peuvent
être réunies dans la crise que nous
traversons pour aller au bout de cette
réforme des retraites je crois que tout
le monde le comprend l'employé de fois
le mot crise au début les crises elles
vont pas s'arrêter dans le prochain
week-end c'est pas tout ça mais c'est
pas tous les jours que vous mettez un
confinement généralisée dans le pays et
vous me l'accorderez c'est compliqué de
porter une réforme aussi importante dans
le contexte sanitaire qui fut le nôtre
il y a un peu plus de deux ans
maintenant aujourd'hui cette réforme des
retraites le candidat hier à présenter
la vision très importante une vision
tournée d'abord sur plus de solidarité
c'est-à-dire une retraite des pensions
minimales à 1100 euros une réforme
également plus juste c'est à dire
continuer à mettre fin à un certain
nombre de régimes spéciaux et de faire
en sorte que les carrières longues les
carrières où il ya de la pénibilité tout
cela puisse être prise en compte et
enfin une réforme qui est tous les
français le savent bien repose sur ce
principe de devoir progressivement petit
à petit travailler plus longtemps pour
aller jusqu'à 65 ans après dix années
d'augmentation progressif une fois que
j'ai dit ça sur la méthode là aussi le
candidat l'a précisé il a mis sur la
table sa vision il y aura évidemment les
discussions et puis le débat
parlementaire puisque à l'évidence c'est
au parlement in fine et que la loi devra
être présenté et débattu mais vous
souvenez juste pardon vous souvenez que
ce qui a bloqué ses pas seulement la
crise sanitaire c'est aussi la pivot à
64 ans c'est ça aussi qui a fait échouer
cette réforme est ce que là on
promettant un âge de départ pour tous à
65 ans qui va encore plus loin que l'âge
de pivot à 64 ans ça peut marcher lors
de la et là aussi il faut être très
lucide d'ailleurs je crois que le
candidat de die comme cela il faut être
très lucide la réforme telle qu'elle
avait été présenté il ya deux ans et
demi de trois ans n'avait n'était
peut-être pas suffisamment
compréhensibles était peut-être
en trou en tout état de cause et c'est
ça qui
n'était pas la bonne et l'on parle plus
d'ailleurs et il sait très important et
c'est en tout état de cause l'adhésion
n'était pas là parce que ça paraissait
pas clair et hier le candidat a posé les
bases d'une réforme plus juste plus
équitable avec cette lucidité de devoir
travailler plus longtemps et en même
temps l'a fait dans une très grande
clarté en disant voilà sur cette base y
aura les discussions y aura le débat pas
commentaire j'insiste sur un dernier
point parce que c'est c'est pour moi
extrêmement important cette réforme des
retraites c'est aussi une réforme du
travail c'est d'avoir la capacité
d'avoir ce pays cette force productive
dans l'agriculture dans l'industrie dans
les services bref avoir cette force
cette capacité productive et souvent on
nous dit oui mais si vous décaler l'âge
de départ à la retraite alors vous
augmentez vous augmenter le taux de
chômage des seniors en fait tout montre
que ça n'est pas le cas parce que quand
vous êtes un employeur
ça n'est pas véritablement l'âge de la
retraite qui fait que vous n'employez
plus les seniors c'est quand la personne
se rapproche de 7h à la retraite et tout
à montrer chez nos voisins qui ont
décalé au fur et à mesure l'âge de
départ à la retraite que quand vous le
des cas liés à son la l'employabilité
des seniors augmenté également je crois
que c'est très important de mettre en
avant aussi cette réforme pour le
travail simplement cette réforme donc
elle doit concerner normalement tous les
actifs à partir de 2023 est ce que ça
suppose quand même pas une concertation
assez idyllique vous avez parlé de
concertation il faudrait vraiment que
les partenaires
sociaux soit soit très vite en accord de
toutes les manières il y aura ces
discussions il y aura ce projet de loi
comme l'a indiqué hier le candidat
puisque il ya eu la question posée en
disant est ce que ce sera par un projet
de loi ou par une ordonnance et ne le
candidat hier à trets montré très
clairement indiqué que ce nom ce sera
parrain par la loi par un projet loi et
non par une ordonnance donc oui il y
aura ces discussions mais ça l'est à
chaque fois on peut poser la question
dans tous les sens faut-il proposer une
base puis ensuite concertées elle est au
parlement ou ne rien proposer
concertée halte et puis aller au
parlement moi je pense que dans une
bonne démocratie c'est normal que le
candidat prenne une position très claire
que cette position elle est désormais
connue de tous elle est soumis donc au
suffrage universel dans le cadre de
cette présidentielle et ensuite il y
aura le travail de concertation par
exemple sur la pénibilité sur la prise
en compte des carrières non etc etc et
le débat démocratique au parlement je
crois que c'est cette ligne qui nous
faut conduire faudel la réforme des
retraites si emmanuel macron est réélu
il aura les mains libres puisqu'il ne
pourra pas être réélu une troisième fois
et c'est la première fois qu'on sera
dans ce cas de figure est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut s'attendre à des
réformes difficiles
il faut aujourd'hui sa tendresse que le
candidat s'il est réélu donc à nouveau
président m mettre en place le projet
qui l'a annoncé hier et je crois que
d'ailleurs c'est une peut-être une
spécificité mais modulo la réforme des
retraites on en a parlé la réforme
institutionnelle qui on le sait a été
empêchée pour des considérants
politiques notamment ici ou au sénat il
y a quelques années au pelage est envahi
la sphère au
delà de ces au delà de ces deux grandes
réformes hier beaucoup de questions ont
été posées sur le bilan et force est de
constater que le président et me
emmanuel macron dans ce quinquennat a
fait ce qu'il a dit qu'il a vu qu'il
allait faire lors de la campagne de 2017
et c'est un gage de crédibilité et donc
demain si les français font à nouveau
confiance à emmanuel macron et bien le
candidat nouvellement président mettra
en oeuvre le projet qui l'a annoncé hier
et le centre juste un mot sur cette
réforme des institutions puisque vous en
parler avant de parler des enseignants
elle a été bloquée par la ferme et nahla
mais bon le président de la république
dit qu'elle a été bloquée faute de
majorité politique en clair parce que le
sénat l'a bloqué c'est ça que c'est une
réalité
ça passerait la majorité sénatoriale va
pas changer
mais après il faut que tout le monde à
sion de ses responsabilités et je pense
que certains ont perdu la boussole de la
responsabilité gérard l'affichette 1er
gérard larcher deux premiers quand vous
voyez les propos qu'il a tenus sur
cette soi-disante petite musique dit
légitimité du candidat élu dans le cadre
de ces élections s'est offert un
responsable d'ixia bâle-campagne la
question de la légitime ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier
y'avait pas de campagne hier et une plus
de quatre heures de discussion avec des
journalistes c'est pas avoir de campagne
cela c'est ridicule c'est absolument il
responsable et on ne peut pas avoir le
deuxième personnage de l'état garant de
nos démocraties qui sous-entendrait que
ces élections ne seraient pas légitimes
qu'en est il alors des élections
sénatoriales
élu sur la base d'un collège les maires
pour lequel le taux d'abstention a
absolument été record y at il un projet
at il un procès en illégitimité
à l'évidence non quand vous êtes un
démocrate un républicain quelqu'un
croyants dans notre démocratie eh bien
vous battez pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'abstention vous battez pour faire
campagne mais vous ne vous battez pas
pour insinuer
quelconque illégitimité quant à une
élection ceci je le redis est grave et
irresponsable et d'ailleurs le le
candidat hier le candidat président hier
le le souligner maintenant voilà il ya
des projets il ya des projets politiques
qui divergent et ses projets politiques
ils doivent être mis à la confrontation
des français il faut aussi avoir en tête
que le candidat il est candidat dès
qu'il le peut mais le candidat il est
aussi président de la république avec
cette mission incroyablement importante
de nous protéger dans le moment
notamment face aux conséquences de la
guerre en ukraine parmi les sujets
importants développeurs d'id à emmanuel
marolle la question de l'éducation tout
à fait alors il a en effet de parler
d'eux le président-candidat bien du
salaire des enseignants alors en
promettant des revalorisations
significative à ceux qui accepteront de
nouvelles missions alors on entend les
mots mais qu'est ce que c'est exactement
ce projet c'est sur la base du
volontariat comme qu'est ce qu'on peut
mettre en pla alors là de la même
manière que je l'expliquais sur la santé
c'est ce chantier de l'école qui doit
incarner également à la fois une
ambition méthode l'ambition c'est quoi
c'est que le ciment de notre république
c'est l'école à l'évidence la première
capacité à la maîtrise de son destin
c'est l'école c'est la formation est-ce
que tout va bien à l'évidence non il
nous reste beaucoup à faire même si
pendant ce quinquennat nous avons
beaucoup oeuvré pour l'école et il faut
le rappeler j'ai été ministre de la
ville et du logement le dédoublement des
classes dans les quartiers prioritaires
de la ville c'est une formidable
réussite
nous avons investi dans le primaire
comme jamais nous avons même investi
d'ailleurs dans les 1000 premiers jours
nous avons investit aussi dans le lycée
mais il reste beaucoup à faire et les
études le montrent donc notre ambition
c'est de consolider l'école qui est le
ciment de notre république comment
deuxième prendra méthodes la méthode là
aussi il faut le faire avec cette
conférence des parties prenantes c'est à
dire du directeur d'établissement en
passant par les enseignants en passant
par les parents d'élèves pour donner
cette un peu plus de liberté dans ce
projet pédagogique
territoire par territoire un peu plus de
liberté également aux professeurs et
l'exemple que donne hier le candidat
c'est dire on voit bien qu'on a un
problème sur leur emplacement si demain
et tous les parents le savent bien
parfois vous avez vous et vos enfants
qui n'ont pas pu avoir le remplacement
de professeurs quand un professeur était
absent est ce que si demain on confie
une nouvelle mission contre une nouvelle
rémunération cela ne peut pas idée
justement le projet pédagogique de
l'établissement à l'évidence oui mais
ces sujets là là c'est un exemple ces
sujets là ils doivent être justement
discuté dans le cadre de cette même et
qu'on comprenne bien parce que jean
michel blanquer a déjà lancé des
augmentations pour les salaires des
enseignants vous reconnaissez ce sont
les chiffres que les professeurs
français sont parmi les moins bien
peignés des pays de l'eu ces deux là ça
veut dire que s'ils veulent être
augmentée il faudra qu'ils travaillent
plus les enseignants ils ne seront pas
augmentés à travail égal est ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'un on a fait déjà
beaucoup de choses et je vous l'avais
dit je vous en remercie 2 il faut aller
plus loin et ce plus loin c'est de
partir du projet pédagogique par les
établissements avec parfois des
spécificités territoriales c'est ce que
nous testons en ce moment même
d'ailleurs à marseille avec cette
volonté d'accompagner au mieux nos
enfants et avec très important cette
considération de nos professeurs on sait
que dans notre pays il y a trop souvent
parfois ce problème de considération de
nos professeurs qui sont nos professeurs
des personnages clés de notre république
seulement ils sont si des haricots de
leur dire ça parce qu'il va devoir
travailler plus et veulent gagner parce
que vous le dit comme ça de dire à nos
professeurs que dans le cadre de cette
méthode il faut définir le projet
pédagogique il faut participer et parmi
les défis qu'on a il y à de nouvelles
missions qu'ils pourraient faire et que
ces nouvelles missions pourrait donner
augmentation de rémunération je pense
que tout le monde ne comprend que c'est
important est que c'est la voie qui nous
faut suivre alors au coeur cette fois je
vous dirais du régalien emmanuel macron
évoque une refonte du modèle
d'intégration républicain
il parle notamment de conditions plus
strictes pour le renouvellement des
titres de séjour il parle aussi
je dirais c'est presque plus étonnants
de l'expulsion des étrangers qui
troublent l'ordre public est-ce que ça
ressemble pas un peu beaucoup à des
appels du pied en direction notamment
des électeurs de valérie pécresse et
vous savez les deux points que vous avez
indiquée sont deux points qui sont déjà
mises en oeuvre y compris le deuxième
s'est déjà mise en oeuvre c'est une
politique que nous avons annoncé il ya
déjà de noix passez donc c'est déjà 1109
quelle est notre position là dessus
c'est fermeté quand il faut être ferme
et humanisme parce qu'on parle de femmes
et d'hommes et d'enfants parfois
fermeté parce que il faut pouvoir
contrôler cette immigration et c'est ce
que nous faisons notamment ferme était
également vis-à-vis des états qu'ils
n'acceptent pas des fameux laissez
passer consulaires c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui a eu une obligation
quitter notre territoire pour des
raisons est que cette obligation de
quitter le territoire n'est pas activé
parce que le laissez-passer consulaires
vous ne l'avez pas bien il faut avoir la
fermeté vis-à-vis de ces pays en disant
si vous n'acceptez pas de
d'accueillir le citoyen de votre pays
que nous avons expulsé alors nous
n'aurons pas la même politique de visas
vis-à-vis de votre pays fermeté et en
même temps humanisme umanis par exemple
entre étant beaucoup plus rapidement les
demandes des demandes d'asile
en l'occurrence sur lequel le candidat
là aussi a exprimé son ambition dessus
fermeté et humanisme c'est quand même un
peu un copier coller du programme de
valérie pécresse ou pas c'est ce qu'a
dit elle la candidate des républicains
que c'est une sorte de copier-coller de
son tram et je la cite a dit c'est du
déni sur les sujets d'ordre républicain
et de contrefaçon sur les retraites le
nucléaire l'agriculture qu'est ce qu'on
voulait répondre et je leur réponds que
c'est assez surprenant de voir que plus
de cinq années après le début de
l'engagement politique d' emmanuel
macron certains n'ont toujours pas
compris
que ce qu'attendait beaucoup de nos
citoyens je crois c'est ce dépassement
hier valérie pécresse dit moi je me
retrouve dans plein de mesures qu'a
exprimée président de la république qui
sont très bien sauf qu'au lieu de le
dire comme ça le dis en disant c'est du
copier coller et y est vous aviez des
candidats de gauche qui disent
exactement la même chose et donc vous
avez des candidats de droite qui disent
oh je dire ah c'est quand même vraiment
vraiment bien ce qui fait il ya des
bonnes mesures ils le disent en fait
c'était mon idée et puis vous avez des
candidats de gauche qui disent
exactement la même chose ça c'est quand
même vraiment extrêmement bien sûr
l'école sur la santé sur cette
émancipation
il m'a copié ça s'appelle en fait le
déplacement c'est à dire que si
quiconque pense qu emmanuel macron a
besoin d'aller copier ici ou là des
mesures je pense qu ils se fourvoient
qu'il se trompe et je pense que ces cinq
dernières années l'ont démontré que
certains se disent c'est quand même
étonnant parce qu'il fait des mesures
que je qualifierais de droit des mesures
qu'il qualifierait de gauche des mesures
qu'il qualifierait de centre c'est que
ces personnes là n'ont toujours pas
compris ce qu'était le dépassement mais
regardez notre gouvernement aujourd'hui
vous avez des personnalités de droite
des personnalités de gauche des
personnalités comme moi qui se sont
construites avec le président de la
république ça s'appelle le dépassement
et si vous voulez un scoop ce
dépassement il va continuer parce que
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'attendent les
français est ce que pour
ça je parle de la fois je fais une bonne
pour
ces sources le dit pas trop dessus ce
n'est qu'en fin je dirai ce que je dis
ce dépassement il va continuer c'est que
cette force politique du dépassement il
va elle va continuer au mit tout
simplement parce que c'est ce que les
français attendent je ne préjugeait en
rien des résultats des élections je me
battre pour que le candidat soit rim
mais ce dépassement politique cette
force politique elle elle va continuer
parce que c'est ce que veulent les
français à l'évidence il faut sortir de
ces clivages n'ont fait qu'on pour tout
simplement apporter les réponses cette
vision ce quotidien
dans son gouvernement et pour être
premier manuel mata il a dit à l'ats la
question qui lui était posée comme cela
il a dit moi je
n'exclus rien parce que j'ai toujours
rassembler les femmes et les hommes de
qualité qui croient dans mon projet et
qui veulent faire avancer la france
voilà les termes qu'il a employés n'a
rien dit de de pluie sur la les termes
qu'il a employés se référant aussi
d'ailleurs à l'excellent ministre du
budget venant de de la gauche qui
n'était pas dans la majorité
présidentielle au début de ce
quinquennat montrant à quel point ce
dépassement il continue il s'opère et je
crois que c est qu on va le préciser
emmanuel macron a commencé son discours
en parlant d'agriculture il en a parlé
très vite notamment il a promis de loi
pour l'installation de jeunes
agriculteurs quai pour en être les
grandes lignes
trois piliers selon moi d'abord un
pilier de de l'éducation agricole
l'enseignement agricole qui est une
chance incroyable dans notre pays très
présente sur notre territoire qui
résulte des lois de pisany de rocard et
qui je crois peut aller encore plus loin
cet enseignement agricole et parfois
méconnu alors que c'est une pépite moi
je me bats pour cet enseignement
agricole deuxième volet l'installation
l'installation des jeunes on sait qu'on
a des défis sur le foncier on peut
imaginer des mécanismes comme le portage
pour accompagner financièrement mais
c'est également l'accès à la terre bref
l'installation comme en accompagne mieux
les jeunes ou moins jeunes ados venir et
à s'installer comme chef d'exploitation
troisième élément l'innovation
l'innovation elle est partout
aujourd'hui dans l'agriculture
absolument partout et d'ailleurs je suis
très frappé moi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de débats quand j'exprime des positions
sur il est possible grâce à l'innovation
d'assumer notre nourricier c'est-à-dire
de produire à la hauteur à laquelle nous
devons produire tout temps même moment
protégeant notre environnement
parce que ça s'appelle le progrès parce
qu'on en a la capacité parce que
l'innovation nous permet de le faire je
suis toujours étonné que certains
n'arrivent toujours pas à accompagner ce
mouvement alors qu'il est là et donc ce
troisième volet de l'innovation est
essentielle bref éducation installations
innovation telle pourrait être être à
présenter quand dès le début du
quinquennat très rapidement parce que
l'enjeu et est absolument immense
d'ailleurs le candidat hier parle de
l'indépendance de notre pays plus fort
en commençant par la défense et ensuite
en paiement
dernière en tout cas rapidement si les
français font confiance au président de
la république actuel candidat pour sa
réélection
alors il ya bien sûr ce contexte
particulier vous chiffrez dirait le coût
de la guerre en ukraine
à combien notamment pour les pour les
agriculteurs c'est très compliqué de
répondre à votre question parce que tout
va dépendre de l'évolution du conflit ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui cette
guerre sur le sol européen un impact
fort pour nos agriculteurs
pour nos éleveurs notamment mais pas que
les maraîchers aussi les producteurs de
différents produits et aliments et et
puis de manière générale dans le monde
agricole parce que vous avez
classiquement trois postes qui explose
en ce moment le carburant le gaz et
l'alimentation animale
et face à ça sans parler même du cours
du blé qui impactent fortement
évidemment
le contexte mais qui me fait craindre
beaucoup plus de conséquences à
l'extérieur de la france notamment au
nord de l'afrique que en france il nous
fallait prendre des objets sur les
conséquences clairement ça veut dire des
pénuries dans les pays du maghreb moi je
suis persuadé que notre responsabilité
du moment c'est d'éviter une famille
pendant 12 à 18 mois je peux pas être
plus clair et ça fait des semaines que
je suis mobilisé là dessus et d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui regardent les propos que
je peux tenir y compris au niveau
européen j'avais déjà alerté dessus il
ya huit mois quand nous n'avions que si
je puis dire la crise des engrais liées
au prix du gaz très très élevé j'étais
tanné j'étais allé par non à bruxelles
en disant à tous mes collègues attention
avec ce qui se passe en ce moment sur
l'engrais dans 18 mois on peut avoir des
conséquences très fort donc une vive
dans les pays du magal une crise
alimentaire est aujourd'hui à cela vient
s'ajouter beaucoup d'autres choses eh
bien demain vis-à-vis d'un arc
méditerranéen qui aujourd'hui dépendant
des importations russes et en même temps
à une sécheresse incroyable et bien vous
pouvez avoir une crise alimentaire
majeure parce que une insuffisance
d'importation de blé dans ces pays-là et
j'alerte pas su ce uniquement j'agis au
niveau national au niveau européen au
niveau international pour faire en sorte
que l'europe se donne les moyens
d'assumer ce rôle nourricier d'acompte
ces pays mais en france on n'a pas ces
risques de pénurie en france on a un
risque effet pris sur les coûts de
production et donc des fragilisation de
nos agriculteurs c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis en place ce plan de résilience ou
rien pour l'alimentation animale c'est
une enveloppe de 400 millions d'euros
les parties comment est-ce qu'on cesse à
la réunion sur la mise en oeuvre des
critères qui seraient définies et
évidemment avec les professionnels a
lieu lundi à mon ministère parce qu'on
veut on a fixé l'enveloppent selon nos
estimations mais on veut s'assurer que
cette aide soit la plus rapide et la
plus précise possible donc la réunion a
lieu lundi à mon ministère ça c'est une
première réponse il ya l'éligibilité
évidemment du monde agricole aux mesures
liées au carburant par exemple la
réduction de 15 centimes ce qui concerne
aussi le gnr mais des remboursements
anticipés de thijs cpe idem sur le gaz
et puis également un accompagnement sur
les charges sociales pour ceux qui sont
le plus en difficulté continuer à
accompagner le temps file nous reste peu
de temps vous me parlez de fait de
risques de famine dans les pieds du mari
est ce qu'un risque et des pénuries
d'aliments en france une en france c'est
toute notre force de la chaîne
agroalimentaire
on a pas de risque de pénurie mais parce
que nous sommes solides parce qu'on a
une chaîne agro alimentaire extrême ans
car ils sont les seuls à sion 17 sur
laquelle on se on se bat depuis deux ans
après sur les prix on est tous lucides
dans le contexte où vous avez le
carburant le gaz l'alimentation animale
et de manière générale les postes de
fabrication qui augmente à l'évidence
sur un impact sur les prix les français
ne voient déjà la réalité soyons tous
lucides là dessus qu'est ce qu'on fait
on se bat pour limiter l'inflation de
manière générale dans notre pays en
jouant justement sur le coût des moyens
de production ce qu'on a fait avec le
plan de résidence sont j'ai quand même
qu'au moment où je vous parle
l'inflation dans notre pays est deux
fois moins élevé que partout en europe
parce que on agit pour ça maintenant il
faut et je le redis que les industriels
la grande île bution jouent le jeu
assument leurs responsabilités pour
faire en sorte que l'inflation
aujourd'hui ne soit pas pris sur les
résultats des agriculteurs mais puissent
être également assumé par les
industriels la grande distribution je
les réunis d'ailleurs tous ce matin même
à mon ministère pour poursuivre
justement ces négociations commerciales
et en dernier monte escalier de réserve
plutôt sur la grippe aviaire on en est
on aujourd'hui on a une situation très
compliquée en vendée avec un phénomène
qui quitteraient nouveau qu'on n'avait
jamais vu la grippe à dire classiquement
ces oiseaux migrateurs qui dépose ce
virus de l'influenza aviaire en
descendant on a eu donc pendant l'hiver
les cas dans le sud ouest on avait dû
abattre trois millions et demi de
volaille et pour la première fois les
oiseaux migrateurs en remontant ont à
nouveau déposé le virus de l'influenza
aviaire cette fois ci en vendée et dans
les alentours et la situation on se bat
on se bat avec force avec les
professionnels avec les services de
l'état veillera d'autres l'abattage à
venir et aujourd'hui on a déjà abattu
plus d'un million et demi de volailles
dans ceux des parts dans ce territoire
on va devoir continuer parce que link le
virus continue à se propager combien
abattage des événements mobiliser pas ça
dépend dé facto du mais voyez des
situations dramatiques pour les éleveurs
et je tiens à le redire 1 on continuera
à se mobiliser pour réussir à contenir
l'influencé agir le plus rapidement
possible 2 on sera évidemment là pour
apporter les aides j'ai réuni tous les
professionnels il ya quelques jours je
vais me rendre d'ailleurs à leur côté
mardi prochain et on continuera à
accompagner mais à terme et il va nous
falloir trouver d'autres solutions sur
cette influence à agir parce qu'on peut
pas laisser nos éleveurs seul face à ce
virus merci julien nord merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité un
plaisir mais partagée merci beaucoup
[Musique]